programm kann man auch schönen guten
morgen schön dass sie bei uns sind als
verteidigungsministerin in diesen
dramatischen stunden wir habe es gerade
gehört wenige stunden schlaf wahnsinn
der letzten nacht wir hören aber auch
gerade aus kabul offenbar dramatische
ereignisse deutsche spezialkräfte ksk
hat den flughafen verlassen erstmals
soweit wir wissen um deutsche
staatsbürger aus der stadt zu retten und
zum flughafen zu bringen höchste
geheimhaltung beim ksk wissen wir alle
aber was können sie uns über diesen ihr
offenbar erfolgreichen einsatz erzählen
das haben uns dann sagen dass die die
lage in kabul sehr sehr angespannt ist
wir haben unglaublich viele flüchtlinge
in der stadt wir haben eine
verschlechterte versorgungslage wir
haben zunehmend auch drohungen auch von
anderen terroristischen gruppen es ist
im moment fast nicht mehr möglich für
bürger und deutsche staatsangehörige
afghanen zum flughafen zu kommen durch
die kontrollen vor allen dingen aber die
menschenmassen am flughafen und deswegen
müssen wir sehr viel stärker dazu
übergeben die leute sozusagen abzuholen
das tun wir und ich kann nur sagen alle
die da vor ort sind machen einen tollen
job dass das ksk ist aber auch die
sanitäter die fallschirmjäger die die
a400m landen unter den schrägsten
bedingungen also ich bin im moment
wirklich unglaublich stolz auf unsere
truppe wurden sie live informiert über
das wird über diese ksk mission also
erstens hat die militärische führung vor
ort etwas besseres zu tun als wir
sozusagen im minutentakt durch zu geben
was ich tue ist ganz selbstverständlich
ich bin mehrmals am tag im gespräch mit
general alt und er weiß er hat jede
operative freiheit die er braucht er ist
der erfahrene mann vor ort das was ich
zu tun habe mit allen anderen im
ministerium ist ihm das zu verschaffen
was er braucht um ganz deutlich zu sagen
was immer da vor ort passiert ich halte
den kopf hin ich halt in den rücken frei
kommandosoldaten in der stadt nicht mehr
am flughafen sondern in der stadt auch
glas präsident joe biden hat letzte
nacht angekündigt er hat gesagt wir
werden nicht genauer hat darüber reden
aber es war schon sehr deutlich dass das
was sie auch eben beschrieben haben die
rettung eigener staatsbürger nicht mehr
möglich ist ohne in die stadt rein zu
gehen ist das was wir in den nächsten
tagen noch deutlich häufiger erleben es
ist eines der szenarien wir arbeiten
natürlich auch auf der politischen ebene
in den verhandlungen in den gesprächen
mit den taliban
dafür zu sorgen dass es sicheres geleit
gibt das slk modell taliban da glauben
weil die sicheres geleit versprechen
bisher
kann ich sagen das was man braucht wird
gewährt die gefahr geht er von diesen
unkontrollierbaren menschenmassen aus
aber auch die müssen geordnet werden
also deswegen wir müssen auf allen
ebenen arbeiten und wir müssen alle wege
offen halten ob das sozusagen zu fuß in
der stadt ist ob das andere
operationsmöglichkeiten sind wie gesagt
es muss vor ort entschieden werden
unsere aufgabe ist es alles vor ort zu
bringen was die männer und frauen
brauchen damit sie ihre arbeit machen
können ksk soldaten zu fuß in der stadt
kabul ein szenario das man sich vor
wenigen wochen noch nicht hätte ausmalen
können erzählen sie uns noch einmal über
die meldung die uns heute morgen
erreicht haben die schüsse offenbar am
tor deutsche soldaten haben das feuer
erwidert was gibt es an neuen details
über dieses feuergefecht es ist genau
diese situation rund um den flughafen
dieser äußere ring tausende von menschen
vorne vor allen dingen zunehmend junge
kräftige männer die auch daran hindern
dass familien zum beispiel durch kommen
können eine maximal steigende
aggressivität dieser dieser wunsch auf
jeden fall noch zum flughafen zu kommen
und es werden waffen eingesetzt und das
haben wir heute nacht auch erlebt hat
schüsse gegeben und die sind auch von
der bundeswehr entsprechend in einem
feuergefecht mit erwidert worden aber
was mir ganz wichtig ist vor allen
dingen auch an die familien unserer
soldaten alle gesund keiner verletzt
niemanden etwas passiert das ist nämlich
das aller aller wichtigste vorgang kann
aber wir müssen über die politische
dimension dieser dramatischen stunden
sprechen deutsche soldaten verwickelt in
feuergefechte deutsche kommando soldaten
die sich zu fuß nach kabul durchschlagen
müssen um deutsche staatsbürger zu
retten all das hätte man deutlich anders
haben können wenn man früher die
familien ausgeflogen hätte ganz klar von
dieser stelle die botschaft auch bild
ist bei den kräften die dort im moment
im einsatz sind aber müssen sie sich
nicht vorhalten lassen dass sie diese
menschen vollkommen unnötig in gefahr
gebracht haben also erstens ist das eine
frage die ich mir jeden tag selbst
stelle und ich könnte mir es leicht
machen und sagen von den 2500 der
bundeswehr ortskräfte sind 2000 vorher
schon in deutschland gewesen wir haben
den kreis erweitert aber was mich
umtreibt ist dass sich jeder einzelne
orts kraft da rausholen will und zwar
jetzt im rahmen der militärischen
evakuierungs mission so gut das geht das
wollen alle nationen aber wir müssen
auch darüber reden weil wir auch noch
ortskräfte haben die nicht in kabul sind
wie können wir sicherstellen dass wir
auch die in einem monat in einem halben
jahr in einem jahr vielleicht nach
deutschland holen und sich erholen das
ist etwas worüber wir reden und ehrlich
gesagt wenn ich mich dazu die taliban
einen tisch setzen muss auch als
regierung dann tue ich das weil das
unsere verpflichtung ist auch gegenüber
diesen arzt man hätte sich nicht mit
diesen steinzeit islamisten die frauen
steinigen die homosexuelle stein legen
die menschen die hände die gliedmaßen
abhaken wollen an einen tisch setzen
müssen wenn sie wenn die bundesregierung
deutlich früher erkannt hätte diese
islamisten diese barbaren sind auf dem
weg nach kabul dann hätte man in dieser
lage gar nicht erst gehabt wie viel
verantwortung trifft sie das persönlich
es gibt zwei punkte die man dazu sagen
muss wie gesagt es gibt die ortskräfte
der bundeswehr und da war klar der
einsatz ist beendet wir holen die raus
und einem großen teil haben es geschafft
dann gibt es die entwicklungshilfe die
noch bis kurz vor dem fall von kabul
gesagt hat auch die un wir bleiben und
auch viele der ortskräfte gesagt haben
wir wollen dieses land nicht verlassen
die sind jetzt sozusagen dieser
allgemeinen evakuierung drin was keiner
in auf dieser welt gewusst hat und ich
darf dann noch mal den chef der
amerikanischen medien generalstabschef
milli zitieren keiner hat diesem
wochenende gewusst und wirklich gedacht
dass kabul innerhalb von zwei tagen
fällt es hat vorher natürlich szenarien
gegeben aber in keinem dieser szenarien
war dieser schnelle fall drin und das
hat uns überrannt das ist der punkt an
dem wir jetzt kämpfen und ich sage ganz
klar man wird alles aufarbeiten müssen
damit wir auch lernen für die zukunft
aber eins ist klar jetzt geht es vor
allen dingen darum unsere männer und
frauen zu unterstützen damit wir so
lange es geht so viele wie möglich da
raus holen haben sie vollkommen recht
unterstützung für sowohl die
staatsbürger als auch unsere soldaten
soldaten fort aber es ist natürlich auch
ein bisschen ein ablenkungsmanöver davon
dass es diese situation niemals hätte
geben müssen haben sie das gefühl
nachdem sie deutsche soldaten in eine
situation geschickt haben die wir in
diesen stunden lebensgefährlich ist dass
sie das vertrauen
da noch genießen wie es sein muss als
verteidigungsminister also das ist eine
frage die die truppe beantworten muss
für mich ist ganz klar ich wenn die
inhaberin der befehls und kommandogewalt
und die muss vorne an bord stehen in dem
moment wo eine so gefährliche
militärische mission läuft in die ich
die leute ja auch geschickt habe wenn
diese mission zu ende ist dann werde ich
für mich selbst sehr genau überlegen
welche verantwortung ich getragen haben
welche verantwortung nicht gerecht
geworden bin wo vielleicht auch nicht
und zu welchen schlüssen ich persönlich
daraus können ziehen muss gestern abend
olaf scholz bevor hierbei bild leifer
noch im kanzleramt den gesprächen mit
angela merkel wir hören dass es da
möglicherweise auch um heiko maas und um
sie um ihre politische zukunft ging
haben sie das gefühl sie genießen noch
als verteidigung des ministerin den
rückhalt der kanzlerin und ich habe den
vorteil dass ich bei diesem gespräch
dabei waren zwar von anfang bis zum ende
es ging darum nicht es ging genau um die
frage wo stehen wir mit der evakuierung
was machen die politischen bemühungen
wie ist das in den usa gibt es
möglicherweise eine verlängerung der
militärischen evakuierung über den 31
acht hinaus etwas was in washington
diskutiert wird also das waren die
fragen auch da ganz klar diese runde hat
damit zu tun dass wir die menschen
daraus lassen sie uns teilhaben an dem
was da auch in washington gerade gedacht
wird und zwischen den verbündeten die
amerikaner haben noch zehntausende
staatsbürger in kabul wie viele deutsche
staatsbürger drin sind ist glaube ich
derzeit nicht ganz genau
abzumessen wie vielerorts kräfte wie
viele angehörige von denen gibt es da
derzeit ein szenario mit militär
wirklich zurück massiv in die stadt zu
gehen also ich sehe dass stand jetzt
nicht ich bin aber auch nicht in alle
ganz aktuellen planungen im pentagon
eingewiesen ich glaube die debatten
laufen was die amerikaner im moment für
sich abwägen ist die frage wenn sie über
den 31 8 bleiben wie hoch ist die gefahr
können sie den taliban trauen wenn es
eine zusage gebe dass sie bleiben können
wie ist es mit anderen terrorgruppen wir
wissen von zunehmenden bedrohungen etwa
durch den er ist das ist die abwägung
weil am ende nützt es auch nichts länger
zu bleiben wenn man dadurch die menschen
eher in gefahr bringen also das sind
ganz schwierige stunden für die
entscheider rund um den globus sie haben
es jetzt mehrfach den taliban trauern
mit den taliban verhandeln die taliban
bitten umgeleitet um abzugsmöglichkeiten
für die eigenen staatsbürger ich fragte
sie das einmal als
verteidigungsministerin aber auch
tatsächlich als frau muss doch das herz
schreien mit solchen leuten die ihre
komplette eigene weibliche bevölkerung
unter die burka sticken stecken und nur
zum tiere füttern vor die tür lassen und
bei vergewaltigung als ehebrecherin
styling mit diesen leuten sich jetzt an
einen tisch zu setzen und darum zu
bitten dass deutsche staatsbürger zum
flughafen fahren dürfen also punkt 1 das
gefühl dass sie beschreiben ist noch
sehr gelinde beschrieben das was wir
vorgehen ich bin in die politik gegangen
damals mit blick auf das thema russen in
afghanistan ich war innenministerin bei
nine eleven und habe diesen einsatz von
anderer art mitverfolgt ich habe immer
dafür gekämpft dass insbesondere die
frauen in afghanistan aber auch anderswo
auf der welt andere rechte haben
insofern ja es tut mir den magen um aber
ich sage es nochmal im moment ist die
situation wie es ist und wenn ich genau
diese frauen vor allem die
frauenrechtlerin zum beispiel aus kabul
raus haben will und wenn ich dann
gezwungen bin wegen der situation dass
wir uns als regierung wer auch immer in
welcher stelle mit den taliban zusammen
setzen und darüber zu verhandeln dann
tue ich das weil es das leben dieser
menschen wert ist und was mein magen
dabei macht das ist meine sache das
werde ich auch überstehen das heißt
deutsche staatsbürger und einige
frauenrechtler sind doch am ende im
moment wichtiger als all die frauen in
der fläche
afghanistans weil derzeit werten wir das
taliban-regime doch ungleich auf bis vor
wenigen wochen hat die westliche
staatengemeinschaft die noch bombardiert
und jetzt sitzen wir mit an ihnen mit
anfangs zwischen um noch einige wenige
leute da rauszubekommen es wird die zeit
geben nach diesem akuten einsatz wo wir
ja auch entscheiden müssen wie gehen wir
mit afghanistan und wie geht das
überhaupt weiter gibt es eine inklusive
regierung ja oder nein wie möglich an
die möglichkeit einer inklusiven
regierung mit diesen ländern ich bin
sehr skeptisch und ob sich alle
versprechen die jetzt gegeben werden
einhalten weiß ich auch nicht aber das
wird die frage dann seien jetzt geht es
um die frage dass die frauen die in
afghanistan sind ob es deutsche sind ob
es afghanen sind ob es andere sind die
sich insbesondere auch für andere frau
in afghanistan eingesetzt haben dass wir
deren leben retten das ist im moment die
hauptaufgabe aber sie haben vollkommen
recht die frage wie gehen wir weiter mit
afghanistan um diese debatte die beginnt
erst dann für mich wenn diese einsatz zu
ende ist raus aus afghanistan retten ist
glaube ich etwas wofür jeder im moment
ein großes herz hat bei der letzten
flüchtlingskrise haben wir dann aber
immer wieder den satz gehört ihr erzählt
uns von frauen und kindern und am ende
kommen junge männer sie erzählen von den
aggressiven jungen männern am tor am
eingangstor zum flughafen wie stellt
diese regierung sicher dass die kommen
die wir retten wollen und nicht die tore
wieder so weit aufgehen wie 2015 wir
sind ja im moment in einer konkreten
evakuierungs mission das heißt wir haben
ja nahmen wir haben identitäten sind im
übrigen auf welche die jeden tag dazu
kommen jeder von uns bekommt sms bekommt
noch namen und aller derer die wir
habhaft werden können versuchen wir raus
zu holen das sind genau familien das
sind insbesondere auch frauen die andere
frage ist und ich bin der auffassung
denen müssen wir auch unseren orts
kräften das aufnahme versprechen geben
dass sie hierher kommen alles andere
wird man sehen müssen wie sich die
flüchtlingssituation in afghanistan
selbst entwickelt wie sie sich in den
umliegenden ländern entwickelt und was
das dann auch für uns bedeutet aber ich
glaube wir haben jetzt erst eine
verpflichtung für diejenigen die so
lange auch für das gestanden haben was
wir westliche werte stehen sie haben dem
ksk zwei hubschrauber nach kabul
geschickt um deutsche staatsbürger eben
auch aus der luft retten zu können sind
die schon im einsatz und wendig wann
kommen sie zum einsatz also sie sind
einsatzbereit ob sie eingesetzt werden
können hängt von zwei dingen ab das ist
zum einen das so auch der
internationalen kräfte auch der
amerikaner weil das muss im luftraum
koordiniert werden und zum zweiten hängt
es vom kommandeur vor ort ab denn der
muss entscheiden habe ich eine situation
wo ich leute besser sozusagen zu fuß
irgendwo raus bekomme oder habe ich die
situation dass sich die
hubschraubereinsätze nochmal gesagt
militärische entscheidung vor ort wir
haben dafür gesorgt ein bisschen dafür
sorgen dass sie alles zur verfügung
haben was sie brauchen gibt einen
berühmten filmen letzte frage vor kam
kam black hawk down über ein sehr
ähnliches szenario beruht auf einer
wahren begebenheit die amerikaner mit
hubschraubern über einer feindseligen
stadt damals war die show heute ist es
kabul graut ihnen nicht vor diesem
szenario deutsche hubschrauber
abgeschossen über kabul natürlich mehr
kraut für jeden verletzten oder
deutschen soldaten aber das ist genau
das risiko und deswegen muss es auch der
militärische führer vor ort entscheiden
ob das risiko eingegangen werden kann
oder ob es andere bessere wege gibt es
geht nicht darum eine show of horses zu
machen oder unkalkulierbare risiken
einzugehen kann eins sagen wenn ich
wirklich zu einem menschen ein
unglaubliches vertrauen habe dann ist es
general alt weil der ist genau in der
lage und er weiß was er tut und er weiß
was er tun kann volker bauer herzlichen
dank für den besuch heute morgen
herzlichen dank für diese spannende
einblicke und auch klaren worte und von
dieser stelle natürlich alles gute an
die soldatinnen und soldaten die sich
derzeit im einsatz in kabul und am
flughafen von kabul befinden und damit
zurück zu thomas kausch und max
[Musik]